so I'm at Chapman University there is my
email address if anybody would like to
email me just write that down McOwen
chapman.edu uh i' love to correspond
with people who have heard my lecture
and have questions and so forth so let's
get started we're talking about Adam
Smith just by a show of hands how many
have never heard of Adam Smith be honest
how many are there anyone here there
there are so are there some people so I
want to talk a little bit about this but
let's start off off by noting uh what
others have said about Adam Smith which
is really quite remarkable so many of
you may have heard of KL Marx and you
have heard of John Mater kees perhaps
but Adam Smith uh is one that everyone
should know about as the founder of
Economics so Wesley Mitchell who is a
Columbia professor said Adam Smith did
for economics in many ways what Charles
Darwin did for biology a new framework
so does that suggest we need to study
Adam Smith indeed it does and uh Jerry
Mueller at Catholic University said The
Wealth of Nations is the most important
book ever written about capitalism and
its moral
ramifications it was intent to make men
better not just better off so I like
that quote a lot and then George Stigler
of uh Chicago Fame said Adam Smith has
one overwhelming important Triumph he
put in the center of economic
the systematic analysis of the
behavior of individuals pursuing their
own self-interest under conditions of
competition and finally Jean bti SE the
great French Economist said when we read
this work The Wealth of Nations we feel
that previous to Smith there was no such
thing as political economy so those are
really some great quotes to introduce
Adam Smith so who was Adam Smith as you
can see from this chart born and raised
and lived in the 18th century from 1723
so what are we celebrating the 300th
anniversary of whose
birth Adam
Smith and that's one reason we're we're
starting the conference off with the
discussion of Adam Smith he would be
300 uh 300 years old today uh and so he
was a Scottish philosopher of the
Scottish enlightenment
uh one of the key figures of the
Scottish Enlightenment and he was a
professor longtime professor at Glasgow
University I was at Glasgow University
this summer for the celebration of Adam
Smith's 300th birthday and it was really
amazing to discover that I didn't know
this but Adam Smith was apparently an
egalitarian and Social
Democrat according to the new
interpretation of the Adam Smith but
he's also famous for two really
important books the theory of moral
sentiments which came out in
1759 and The Wealth of
Nations
1776 which is a big fat book came out in
two volumes in on March 9th
1776 and it was a declaration of
economic independence because notice the
year it came out the same year of the
Declaration of political Independence a
much smaller doc
but of equal importance uh by Thomas
Jefferson so that's just a little bit of
a background of Adam Smith he never did
marry by the way he was a confirmed
Bachelor all of his life uh no children
uh but uh has a major Legacy in his
work so what can we learn about Adam
Smith now this kind of heavy I don't
know how well I guess you can read all
this so Adam Smith
it can be labeled in my opinion a
multifaceted genius for making the case
for specialization and division of labor
is the key to economic growth and
productivity for his devastating
critique of
protectionism and advancing
globalization and free trade the
counterproductive unintended
consequences of centralized planning
under the mercantilist model and for
popularizing the term the Invisible Hand
to describe the market
economy so this is here's a quote from U
from Benjamin fredman Benjamin fredman
is the other fredman many of you may
have heard of Milton fredman at
University of
Chicago raise of hands how many have
heard of Milton fredman okay most of you
how many have not heard of Milton
fredman same people for the Adam Smith I
don't
know
um economists aren't as famous obviously
as uh a lot of the politicians that we
deal with today um but uh the other
fredman is Benjamin fredman he says
something very interesting in uh a
recent book uh he he said here there is
no there's a challenge here that's
really important what was Adam Smith
trying to what was he trying to discover
so what he was trying to discover is
something that has really uh perplexed a
lot of philosophers over the ages he
undertook a bold and controversial
course of action he sought to find a way
to transform the vice of private
selfishness into a public
virtue in doing so building an economic
model that could revolutionize Human
Action one that made people better not
just better off and of course he relied
on others other experts over the years
other philosophers but he's the first
one who really put it
together and so here is the Adam Smith
challenge okay here's the Adam Smith
challenge that all of you would probably
wonder about one that I have and other
words in Adam Smith's day giving
political democracy and economic freedom
of Choice was thought to be
dangerous and could easily lead to chaos
Anarchy and even
violence hadn't s Laz Fair policies in
the past led to social unrest forcing
the monarchy to impose order and the
rule of law so that's where this quote
from Benjamin fredman comes into
place there was no presumption that
peoples pursuing their own
self-interest would have any more
broadly beneficial consequences quite
the contrary so much so that acting
purely on one's individual self-interest
taken as a vice and the standard
adjective to such Behavior was
vicious before then the mercantilists of
the 17th century had likewise been
skeptical that individually motivated
Behavior could make a nation better off
their approach was to run economic
affairs from top down so that that
should give you an indication of the
huge challenge that Adam Smith had how
is it possible that we could see
individual self-interests lead to the
public
benefit so according to Adam Smith
humans could be honest hardworking fair
in their commercial activities but at
the same time they could be selfish
greedy lustful and engage in frauds and
deception in business that we've all
seen and take advantage of government
privilege to promote Monopoly power
corruption and
waste so in fact most people you're
you're familiar with the Invisible Hand
doctrine that the pursuit of
self-interest should lead to public
benefit but he actually in in the end of
book one of The Wealth of Nations he
excor
Ates the traders who engage in here's
what he says that he said the interest
of the dealers the traders in any
particular trade or manufacturer is
always in some aspects opposite that of
the
public so to widen the market and to
narrow the competition is always the
interest of the
dealers and they this order of men have
generally an interest to deceive and
even OPP oppress the
public so you can see this is a very
tall order on behalf of Adam Smith to
try to make this great achievement so
how does one reconcile these statements
from Adam Smith in the Invisible Hand
doctrine that PS by pursuing one own
interest he frequently promotes that of
society so how is it possible to develop
an economic model that can could
encourage the positive
virtues of thrift industry prudence and
benevolence looking out for the other
man or woman and at the same time
diminish the selfish passions of
Newton which is true for many of the
philosophers in the Scottish
Enlightenment in particular back in the
18th century so Sir Isaac Newton here's
a statement from noris hington who is a
in a story and he says Adam Smith's
effort to discover the general laws of
Economics were directly inspired and
shaped by the example of Newton's
success in discovering the natural laws
of course so those of you who are in
physics if we have any physics majors
here or in the past you know that that
Newton's Laws of motions explained an
orderly and harmonious Universe based on
the three laws of motion Newton could
propose such universal laws as
gravitational pole is inversely
proportional to the square of the object
distant from the earth so he he came
through with these great breakthroughs
uh in these uh laws of motion by the
same token Adam Smith was inspired to
create Newtonian economics where the
economy like Newton's Universe was
orderly and
self-regulating after observing some
simple rules of human
behavior you can see this in The Wealth
of
Nations with now this supply and demand
graph which all of our students know
about it wasn't in Adam Smith's wealth
of nation didn't show up 100 until years
later with Alfred Marshall but I show it
here the supply and demand curve where
you can see why there is a tendency
toward equilibrium but notice the
statement that Adam Smith makes in book
one uh of The Wealth of Nations where he
says where the quantity bought to Mark
brought to Market is just sufficient to
supply theual effectual demand and no
more the market price naturally comes to
the Cent Central price to which prices
of all Commodities are continually
gravitating Can You Feel The Newtonian
aspect gravitating Central equilibrium
model it's very much imitating Newtonian
economics so how did he achieve this
great
success what was the secret to Smith's
system to allow a free market commercial
Society to function successfully to
benefit all
and be
stable and what's interesting is uh I
actually
discovered that Adam Smith has one
paragraph heck it's one sentence in The
Wealth of Nations one
sentence where he describes his
Discovery but guess what it's on page
561 you have to go through
561 pages to come
to this solution that Adam Smith has on
how to create an economic system that
encourages gives incentives for us to
have a higher uh uh standard of living
and yet minimize the frauds and
deceptions and the selfishness and greed
that is part of human nature how can you
do
this so here it is
this is found on
page is that 5 561 right 651 you even
have to go 100 Pages
more the book is only 900 Pages you have
to go through 2third of this book have
anyone in this room read the Adam The
Wealth of
Nations wow we should give special
credit to every one of them this is it's
a tough book Abel and Gary you you
didn't raise your hand and not the whole
thing not the whole thing not the whole
thing I have actually read it cover to
cover so that's why I'm here and you're
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there okay so let's see if you can find
I've made it easy the words are
italicized okay so here is a quote and
says every man as long as he does not
violate the laws of justice is left
perfectly free to pursue his own
interest in his own way and to bring
both his industry and capital into
competition with those of any other man
or order of
men so what are the three elements of
Adam Smith's model where he solves this
great issue that has been bothering
economists for years and philosophers
you've got to have a system of justice
you have to have maximum
freedom and you have to have a robust
model of competition and if you have
that you will achieve this
tremendous uh goal this tremendous
benefit and what are the benefits this
is an amazing thing Adam Smith promised
three things if we adopt his
model